Ariana
hello Look Who's Back
where have you been Helen back but
mostly um San Fernando Valley
El Monte
El Sereno Whittier Compton Long Beach
anywhere I just keep it moving you know
what's been going on in your life
well who had to take a deep breath for
that one though
a lot of negativity you know
um
dealing with my um homelessness
I've been getting jacked for all my
stuff like you know literally my price
is worth of stuff cell phones all my
clothes the only things I had on my back
on a daily basis it's like you know I
have to you know re-up on the stuff that
I lost but it's only materialistic but
as a female it means a lot to me because
I chose that stuff you know it was my
birthday stuff too my birthday is coming
up April 14th I'll be um 29.
so I read up on like jewelry hygiene and
stuff
so I don't know I guess you know doing
with the gear that I get like you know
expensive brands people scope it out and
then like end up jacking me for it
are you still using
um
on and off yeah crystal meth
pretty much yeah you see more uh relaxed
more relaxed now than you were last time
well like I said the the jokes are over
the it's not immaturity it's like like I
said I'd rather take you know life as a
joke
but this time it wasn't a joke this time
I ended up getting really badly hurting
I got beat up again
and um he beat me very bad you know just
for a cell phone too and I literally had
like a black eye with the green and
purple busted lip and
it was so traumatizing I was going to
commit suicide that day and um
someone walked into my suicide scene and
stopped me his name was Matthew
and I'm saying what are you doing
and it's just that me and the guy had
you know something going on
and just I was lying on the on the
shower floor just rubbing myself up and
down like you know couldn't feel my
myself you know feel dirty enough that
it's filthy hands were all over me that
the day before of
and then he just tripped after smoking
that fentanyl crap and then he just beat
me up for my phone
and it was just like every time I looked
in the mirror and I seen my black eye in
my face I got flashbacks
and I just couldn't bear with it anymore
I was trying to commit suicide
I was gonna if it wasn't for my friend
Matthew to walk in um I probably would
have been light out with my wrist open
and it was just you know
I don't know how guys can put their
hands on women
mind you I'm pregnant
but um a lot of people think I'm lying I
already tested and the two lines come up
now I'm three months pregnant from a
dude in San Fernando who's the father
Jose
Mexican guy from Oaxaca Mexico in the
portinia centers homeless encampment in
San Fernando in Northridge actually not
the guy that hit you not the guy that
hit me the guy that hit me was actually
my enemy and like okay like I said
I should have known I was playing with
fire again and um I was just vulnerable
at the time and I didn't have nowhere to
go so I skipped on and you know got into
an Uber kicked it with him in an
apartment building and he smoked that
crap and then just tripped on me
but um
yeah yesterday I was actually crying
just down the road right here because
there's this guy who's gonna kick it
with me but and then he says where
you're not giving up the [__] so what's
up you know and I like I was like how
disrespectful is that
you know only because you don't give up
you know you're one of you know he
should have told me what it was and what
it wasn't you know I thought we were
trying to kick it smoke chill whatever
but all to him it was just you know
getting inside you know between my legs
and
it sucks because like at times like this
when your family you would think that
your family would try to help you but
all they say is go to rehab go to rehab
go to rehab to think they would try to
understand you somewhat
like my question is how are you supposed
to graze her for someone if you just
lose another one and another one another
one in a matter of 30 days you lost like
at least
15 individuals I lost my grandma due to
kovid I remember the last time I came
she was alive she died from covet
I wasn't allowed to a funeral because my
family said I was disgraced to the
family because I caused her enough hurt
and I literally cried because like she
raised me from like 10 months born mind
you till I was like 18.
she was practically my mom she took me
in
and um I couldn't go to her funeral
because they said if I bothered to show
up
um they would call my PO and call the
cops if I bothered to show up so they
told me to save myself the humiliation
and the embarrassment and not to show up
and she spoke for the whole family
which is one of my aunties
and um
it's just like I don't even bother
calling them anymore because like
when it was the holiday like Christmas I
called them just to say hi you know hi
and she goes Ariana why do you keep on
insisting on calling you know you're not
allowed over here on the holidays or at
all
type of stuff you know
but last time when I was staying in El
Salvation Army it was her dropping off
my Christmas presents
to me and now it's not even no Christmas
presents it's just uh just reassure
yourself you can't even show up to our
house type of stuff you know
so it's like
Times Like These when you feel like
well I know I'm alone I on a daily basis
I struggle with trying to find out where
I'm gonna lay my head you know
who I'm gonna run into on a bad note or
on a good note
it used to be a very nice girl to all
this stuff that happened to me
on a traumatization note
I just I'm not used to people being nice
to me you know
so
sorry
it's like coming from in here
I'm only human I only you know [__] eat
and bleed and cry
I can only hold it for so much longer
but yeah when I do cry I just can't stop
it because I don't cry on a normal basis
I don't like showing my weakness you
know
and it's like someone that I know that
says you're not hard it's all the front
he says yourself that's a pillow type of
stuff and I'm like
ouch you know
because let me tell you I can handle an
ass beating I got chicken wing not long
ago
from um what was it downtown or Burbank
Police I got arrested for being under
the influence of a controlled substance
and mind you they didn't even mirandize
me
so their case goals to hell I Googled it
I said what if they don't mirandize you
it says that they're um
pretty much their evidence is
no good you know it's income incompetent
but um I'm pregnant again and like I
said and um I plan to to reunite with
the baby daddy just to you know talk
about stuff like that because he has a
little like shed that he created himself
but mind you it has freaking like power
and everything you know how they hook up
the lights and stuff
and um see what what he's he's gonna do
for me if not you know look for like
resources for programs I've been trying
to get into one but
I really don't want a program I just
want like my own apartment a motel or
something
not some structured program is going to
tell me because mind you I went to a
program last time it was called um
the project 180
um you know Sun Valley one I stayed
there for five months I almost graduated
till the covet outbreak happened half of
the house caught it and I thought it was
a smart idea to go use meth and run off
and kill my five months program
and um awald
just to go across the street in the
trailers in Sun Valley where all the
drug heads kick it but I wasn't ready to
relapse then because I answered there
and I seen a guy with a pipe as soon as
I seen the pipe I said I'm not gonna
throw away my sobriety like this
and I ran out and I said I was gonna go
look for a bathroom at McDonald's and I
went back to the rehab and sat there and
cried for like two hours and they
wouldn't let me in they said show us
that you could stay sober for the next
two days and then come back Monday
and then we'll talk
and I did it and then we talked
but then again it's like a rehab and
it's full of all women mind you I only
kick it with just men because women and
I don't get along because of my pretty
face they get jealous and insecurities
about their boyfriends or their homies
they they know that the attention is
like not going to be just all on them
you know but I can care less I'd rather
be ugly than pretty because pretty girls
get it
like and like what are good looks good
for you know modeling and movies type of
stuff I'm not an actress I'm just a
homeless female out here you know
surviving
but I just feel like if it's not the
cops it's my enemies and if it's not my
enemies it's me going to jail bro you
know I'm gonna get killed by somebody
and it's like on a daily basis you hear
news about like girls going missing and
stuff like gunshots to their head
pregnant or not
you know and then I have my
ex-boyfriends make comments like oh
you're gonna end up just like the Brenda
Paul's chick
was the Emma snitch and I'm like wow
really he's like yeah because you talk
too much you run your mouth too much
type of stuff
and then it's like
death
it lurks around you so much I'm like I'm
not scared dude
you know
on the suicide ideations
I'm trying to make it for me and my baby
I already feel like bad
a bad mom that I can't do it for my
first son because my baby daddy and I do
not have a good relationship anymore we
can't even stand talking to each other
he just throws me on my you know but
like oh Jonathan Needs Mom you know
um are you ready to be a mom you should
go to rehab where do you go to the detox
are you ready for a program you know
just pushing me and pushing me and
pushing me instead of saying so have you
thought about it have you know have you
considered taking a program are you
ready can you at least give it a try
type of stuff you know like try to you
know boost me up there instead of he
knocks me back down you know
and
I don't know what to do anymore
I'm a good person I really am but
I just been through so much [__]
it just sucks
my smile like by the end of the day by
when it turns dark you won't see me
smile until it turns light again because
in the dark this place is scared roll I
almost got kidnapped out here by a bison
literally got up
seat burned because he yanked me when I
told him I wasn't gonna give him head
for five dollars
you know and I've been mistaken for an
informant and been held you know and
captive and stuff like that
and then you know I had to engage in
stuff
that I didn't want to
and then you know I'm like hurting from
my private area and like bleeding and
stuff like that
but you know
who's gonna believe me type of stuff you
know
I was asking for it type of stuff nobody
asked for it you know what I mean no is
no and that's that
but like I said if my situation people
take
advantage of it
and you know
they'll they'll be nice and be like kick
it kick it and then later they're like
oh well I smoked you out with this much
I fed you I did do this what you got in
change for me you know because nothing's
free in this world
you know that's why I'd be careful who I
kick it with try and make sure that it's
gonna be enough you know you're doing me
a favor you're gonna charge me later on
type of thing
but um
I've talked to a lot of high school
friends and um
apparently like
I have more people on my back than I
thought I did
you know because I was off of social
media since I got my my couple cell
phones robbed for me I thought it was
better to be without a cell phone but
like let's say three o'clock in the
morning when you know you're in certain
areas and then
you're being chased by certain vehicles
by myself you know
it's just it's a scary situation
it's those moments that I start to pray
and I'm like please God like don't let
me get you know hurt right now type of
stuff you know
I don't know why people do me the way
they do I'm
I'm just the way I am because of you
know what I've been through
but um
I'm I'm trying to make it out there man
it's I'm still homeless like I said
I just I get with people that you know
gang bangers or places and stuff and
they still they they're like so much
alike domestically violent they're all
just
physical and it's not cool man what do
you think it would take for you to put
down the drugs
some support
would be great first of all
and um guidance would be a second step
for that one
and three like
goals
you know like a little plan an action
plan you know I've been in rehab
because I said I was there for like five
months but before that I was going to DD
Hirsch Mental Health Services
I'm not dumb I just do dumb things and
while I'm under the influence half of
the time I'm not thinking of what I'm
doing I'm just acting on impulse because
I'm working with I'm mad at the world
because a lot of people do me dirty and
I'm trying to get even type of thing
you know because who steals from a
person who's already in the streets you
know and the cops look at me and they're
like you don't live in the streets look
at you you're clean so let's call the
motel room homie or just boil some water
in the hot pot you know and bird bath
or the mobile showers you know
but um
I I just
I'm upset with myself that I've
let myself get the way I am like looks
wise I have like pimples
of like irritations going on with my
eyes
a lot of people smoke in that fentanyl
stuff I did overdose off of fentanyl
again
I shot up 30 cc's of pure Fentanyl and
they had to Narcan me three times right
here in skid roll
so my boy gave me it and I he said it
was G Funk but it wasn't crystal meth
and I guess I died and I don't remember
anything I honestly don't
but they said they not can meet three
times to bring me back
and it's like I've had more than nine
lives so obviously I'm here for a reason
and
like I said probably it's just to give
motivation to those females that are out
there doing the same thing because
I do miss the hell out of Narcotics
Anonymous you know but I can't be like
faking the funk like how am I gonna sit
there and just pretend to like listen to
the message but pretend that I'm sober
because you know I'm not sober and the
meetings when I would go to them I was
sober but with the support of my baby
daddy but now that me and him are not on
talking terms and it's always um do you
have some money John and he's like
um no Ariana I don't I'm at work right
now can you like hurry up I gotta go
type of stuff you know the father of
your second one is just somebody you
just met no I was staying with him for
like a matter of months we were in a
relationship to like he dragged me out
the tent like half naked and um I had to
call out for help to one of my guy
friends Diablo and um yeah I had to call
out for help and he's like you know what
you keep on running back to the Mariana
I don't know what to do anymore that's
the second time I rescue you like if you
go back to him the next time like I
don't want to hear you yelling you know
so I just dipped from that spot too and
it's like
I just look for a one woman man and all
these men out here just want to have
more than 10 females that's how STDs get
caught
a lot of guys like to offend me and say
that I'm some type of hoe that I'd be
effing everybody in their mamas but
that's not true I bet you that I can
prove an STD clean test more than half
of these females out here because if I
do do my stuff I do it with protection
no glove no love you know but that's my
problem and then like someone yesterday
made a comment says damn so it didn't
make it with the South cider so you pick
a wood I'm like [__] dude that's so
offensive so I was kicking it well still
am kicking it with some white boys right
mind you I'm a sucker for white boys I
kick it with them and um because they're
the coolest people on Earth they won't
do you in they actually have everything
that you know you don't have and then
like let you chill with them and not tax
you later and type of stuff you know
they'll be like oh yeah let's chill you
know don't trip it's on me you know type
of stuff not the um I'll charge you
later type of stuff you know what I mean
and it's like
for him to say that well homegirl didn't
work out with the south side if you want
to kick it with a wood wood I'm like wow
that's offensive I'm a grown-ass woman
and I'll have to explain to nobody what
I do or who I kick it with whether the
race or not you know
I don't know what what it is with racism
but that's like half of the negativity
in this world racism
and procrastination is another one and
three the government did you notice all
these viruses and stuff have been going
out because I think the government is
honestly trying to end civilization
first the covid virus and then the what
the West Nile Virus and now the freaking
influenza like are you serious
and then like now they're making drones
and and freaking robots with machines on
them like I don't know what the hell the
government's doing but after Joe Biden
went president it's a sick joke
you know
do you have any contact with your family
at all
absolutely not
I just saved myself from that hassle
because every time I do end up calling
them I end up in tears
you know because like one time I try to
ask for my ID
and I kind of make a prank on my aunt
and I told her I was calling well I told
my friend to make a joke call saying
that she was calling from the morgue
and my aunt took a very very personal
she says I am calling from the morgue
I'm just here to
um ask you to come in and identify the
body she's like what
and then she's like click she's like
[__] You Ariana I can't do this anymore
I was like [__] you dude why did you do
it she's like I can't do it call your
your aunt back right now and let her
know that it was a joke I'm like no [__]
that letter word letter word some of my
aunt's like you think it's funny she she
like literally called the cop saying
that I was like missing and then I was
like oh no so I called her and she's
like do you think it's funny she's like
you think it's funny to say that you're
calling from the more to identify your
body I'm like but you don't care about
me right type of stuff and then when it
comes like that like if you don't fix
your stuff with people and then you just
let them die that's your conscience
being like Oh I should have you know
asked him for his for his forgiveness of
you know by by doing this person dirty
you know because when that person is
gone they're gone
like my grandma you know my grandma from
my mom's side also died from cancer and
then my little brother died from
fentanyl he was 25. he um he lived in
Las Vegas his name was Kevin Howard
obviously he was dealing for some
full and um he had a bunch in his sock
and it bursted and it went through his
pores and he was 25 years old I didn't
get to meet him but I had a very good
relationship with him I still go through
the messages on on my Facebook
and um
my Facebook is Sola Potrero
s-o-l-a and then
p-o-t-r-e-r-o that's my fake name but
yeah that's my most recent profile
in my personal people get to you know
hit me up on there
but yeah I just barely got another phone
thanks to my white friend
I love white people white people are
awesome my baby daddy's white you know
my son's white come on now racism needs
to stop sometime because if not you know
like I said I feel like there's gonna be
a race war one day
people always making like stupid
comments like Fu you at Mexican [__]
and I'm like what the [__]
I'm like rude and I literally got spit
in the face by a black man I only
believed to beat the black off of him I
beat him up I stored I did it was so
disrespectful if I had a dollar for
every time I bit spay on my face it's
like the most disgusting coolest thing
ever it's like
it's
um
it's un uncalled for
you know it runs rough it Rose rough
life's rough you know and and drugs are
with it too it just keeps the gnarly and
the and the J cats and the weirdos and
you know everybody belongs in one place
and that's good I call it skit hoes for
you
know tap tap on that one cash out later
you know she'll take one for the team
you know we'll talk about it later you
know just don't let her hear about it
we'll speak about it type of stuff you
know just let her chill for a minute
she'll get it you know she'll get it
with the program you know what I mean
you know like whatever but by the end of
the night or day like I said I'm the
only one standing G's up hoes down I've
never switched and you know
I run by myself I stay by myself and I'd
rather be alone than
bad accompanied
and misery Love Comes loves company and
that's why half of these men are alone
in this world and I'd rather be single
ready to mingle than be you know with
somebody who's gonna put his hands on me
or you know lower my self-esteem because
as you can see
I dolled up besides the running mascara
speaking from the core you know my
feelings and all
it's been tough but you know I'm an
unborn child I'm just trying to get out
the streets before I get hurt again and
that's all I asked for just to get out
the streets you know for someone to
actually keep me on my toes you know
some guidance some support would be
great because with the stuff that I've
been through like I said standing over
like you know El Monte riverbed just
contemplating I'm throwing myself off a
bridge
it's not cool you know Ariana what would
you say is the most important thing
you've learned in your life you're 29
years
the most important thing that I learned
is that
my my grandma as my guardian wasn't
trying to be strict on purpose she was
just trying to save me from the Big Big
World if it wasn't me for me to go
against her word and like sneak out the
house and stuff like that I would have
been inside the house at home not
knowing what's out there like the drugs
the party scene and all that that would
have waited to like after school I think
I would have been fine but since I
sneaked off and smoked weed here drink
the beer here got my tattoos on you know
behind my back type of stuff
I think I would have been fine but
curiosity kills the cat and if anything
I would have been dead
it's just like
I just learned that the party scene is
always going to be there the drugs are
always going to be there everything will
always be the same and the world is just
going to keep on going round and round
and round and you're the one that's
gonna end up beat up tore up inside hurt
emotionally and physically you know
because
um I was like 225 pounds like three
months ago and I'm down to my 100s now
with appetite being gone you know
smoking bowls and stuff it's just
I want to stop but I kind of don't want
to stop because I depend on the drug
tune you know cure my multiple diagnosis
type of stuff
and I know that heroin is not for me
because it's it gets my depressions
going and it's a sick joke the come down
is disgusting so I just stick to crystal
meth and Crystal myth only but hopefully
if I get myself right I'll be in a
program soon
and yeah for all those people that were
asking for a follow-up
here you guys have it
I'll be fine you know
I'm still who I am just a little bit
more serious now I'm not the you know
fun Jolly girl that was you know taking
everything as a joke because like I said
joke was on me I ended up getting hurt
like really really bad this time and
like my eye was shutting and I could
barely see out and I was just yelling I
just want my phone and the cops were
like
is that the dude that did that to you
and I'm like looking at him I'm like
I'm like I'm like I'd rather not say I
just gotta go I gotta go you know that
much fear you know that pumps inside of
me
because
I don't know what his reason was
under influence or not I think people
should know right from wrong but putting
your hands on a female is just way up
just I'm like pull on boom boom boom
just
like stomping me out to my head I had
knots everywhere
but scars are scars and you know battle
wounds Wounded Warrior projects
yep
and yeah Ariana thank you so much for
coming back thank you guys for asking
for a follow-up appreciate lots of luck
with your new baby
thank you you're gonna have to put down
that crystal meth
I will all right John thank you very
much thank you